hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2018 Sinquefield Cup it's a
game between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura now I will also show the game
between Lebanon and Alexandria although
this game did have a greater impact
understandings of the entire event so I
decided to show this one first but I
will show the other one today as well
before we check out the game I would
just like to briefly address the whole
matter of copyright infringement st.
Louis chess club had here against me
they contacted me yesterday and in their
email they said that they discussed the
whole matter with their attorney and
they decided that I have in no way
infringed their copyrights so I decided
you know not even talk about this
anymore but then I saw a tweet by Peter
Svidler on Twitter
he said that me showing the email was a
douche move and now there there are
there's a very nice reason why me
showing the email was not a douche move
the email from which I was contacted by
Tammy is already a public email it's not
her private email or anything it's an
email that can easily be found under
contacts of the st. Louis Chess Club
website on the other hand the contents
of the email are is not a private matter
it is I mean they are basically
threatening to sue me or you know take
down my channel which is a pretty big
thing to me if I don't comply with the
request which is to take down my videos
I do not intend to take down my videos
so I mean if they wanted they could
probably take down my channel as YouTube
doesn't really care who's right they
just don't really like disputes but near
the email that was used to address me
nor the contents of the email or a
private matter so I can I really don't
see how that is a douche move I mean and
I say this with the utmost respect for
Peter Svidler he is he is one of the
greatest chess commentators in the world
he is one of the strongest chess players
in the world not only that he is a he's
a legend hearthstone player so I really
do have the the utmost respect for him
and I don't I don't know if he's just
siding with them be
he is currently their employee or that
is his real opinion but regardless of of
everything that is not a private matter
so that being said they said that this
is not copyright infringement and you
know nothing will most likely happen to
my channel but you know we'll see how it
goes
I was not I was not impressed how this
whole thing turned out so regarding this
game getting back to it like we said it
was it's a game from the final round of
the 2018 single cup Carson has the white
pieces as going into this round karana
is in the lead by half a point if Carson
wants to make anything he definitely has
to win this game because it's very
unlikely that karana will lose his game
and even if he loses his game and calls
and draws then he's just going to you
know be even so he definitely has to win
this game so it's very interesting how
this whole whole thing turns out he
opens with Knight to f3 in the reti
opening Knight to f6 d 4e 6 c4 in the d5
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined as of course we always
transpose into the Queens gambit
declined recently Knight to c3 Bishop to
e7 Bishop to f4 we have castles III and
b6 now going into the hobbits variation
Bishop to d3 the chapters on c4 a
standard theme like black will wait for
white to develop the light square bishop
and only when the light square bishop is
developed will then only capture on c4
and making white waste the tempo and now
brush up to a six now we have Queen to
e2 Bishop captures Queen captures in the
now c5 d captures on c5 we have B
captures on c5 and now cross and castles
it seems a bit odd to play this d
captures on c5 move you know why would
you why would you trade from the center
but now after all is said and done the
material is equal on the board or cousin
has two connected pawns on the Queen
side whereas Nakamura has two isolated
pawns on the Queen side so
what white will want to do definitely
cousin will want to make these two pawns
a target how will he do it well let's
just see knight c6 Nakamura develops the
night
rotate the c1
preparing the the rook to attack the c5
pawn rook the c8 countering the rook and
now Knight to e5 here nakamura could
definitely exchange captures captures
and then go Queen b6 Ted protection to
the c5 pawn and also go for the b2 point
but Nakamura decides to keep the tension
on the board Queen to b6 now Carlsen
exchanges on c6 and here we have rook
captures on c6 b3 as the beat upon was
under attacked h6 and now comes rope to
d1 h6 probably he wants to make some
room for the king so you know it often
is a useful move but right in this
position I don't think Bishop to g5 was
ever a threat perhaps he wants to do
something like Knight h7 to g5 but I
don't really see the real idea behind h6
I'm sure there is one but it is far
beyond me oh okay look after d1 Queen -
b7 with ideas of guarding the d7 square
if any changes are made for example on
e4 then the Queen is already guarding
the d7 square we have h3 by Carlsen
again also making room for the king and
perhaps making an escape route for the
Bishop rook F to c8 doubling up on the C
file and now Knight to a4 and we have
Knights the d7 by Nakamura adding
further protection to the c-51 and also
planning Knight b6 to exchange Knights
rook to d2 we have Knight captures -
Knight captures and here a very
interesting moment in the game Nakamura
goes rook captures on v6 pawn captures
and b6 does seem like an automatic thing
to do you know you get rid of your two
isolated pawns now you have to connect
the passed pawns no not passed pawns but
two connected pawns but
Nakamura prefers to capture with the
rope here you would also get to Roxy to
d1 like what happened in the game and a
similar position would most likely arise
after rook d7 Queen goes here and they
for defending the pawn now black would
want to infiltrate the position via
Queen to b4 and here we would most
likely have the same thing that happens
in the game this Bishop captures on h6
idea
and then black would be black would
waste upon but here Queen to b4 can be
played and then black gained some
activity if the Queen's are exchanged
then black it gets an open C file for
the rooks but it would be very
interesting because here G chapters and
h6 would lose the Queen to G for check
King to h8 and now rook captures on f7
attacking the bishop Queen h5 capturing
here is an idea also the rock is coming
the other rock is coming to d7 black
would be lost here and it's a very
interesting variation because it's
similar to what happened in the game
after Knight captures Nakamura played
rook after some b6 Roxy d1 now cross and
doubles up on the D file threatens rook
to d7 and we have Bush up to f6 Nakamura
allows it rock to d7 between two a6
offering to trade Queens and now Queen
to e4 here cross and is preparing Bishop
captures on h6 and Hiro Nakamura plays
the strongest move recommended by the
engine he 5 he calculated precisely that
this is no threat for black and although
I mean who would want to allow this with
black it's very interesting he
calculates precisely and sees that this
is this is fine for him so okay Carlsen
goes bush up characters on aged six and
now what do you play here like in the
variation that we just checked out if G
captures on h6 black is lost here but
not because of the same idea Queen g4
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find why black would be lost here
what move wins the game for white for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
rook captures on f7 the idea is Queen to
h7 checkmate if you want to prevent this
you have to capture the rock but then
Queen to h7 comes nonetheless
King moves and now comes Rock to b7 and
there is no defense against Queen to f7
checkmate you can give up you know some
material before checkmate really happens
but those are silly moves so yeah after
Bishop captures on h6 rook to e8 was
played and cousin said that when he saw
this rook to e8 move that he was very
impressed by Nakamura's defense and saw
that he doesn't really have all that
much
Queen to g4 now pinning the g7 pawn and
now
Himura in cold blood captures on a two
so he says across and you have nothing
here and Carson agrees he pushes efore
if he goes for something like rook to d6
to threaten to exchange rooks maybe
bring the other rock over threaten the
bishop then black and simply play
captures captures and queen to be one
chick after he moves now the Queen can
retreat and black defends black defense
properly here and there is nothing for
white to look for here so here after
Queen captures on a to Causton goes
efore after such a such an exchange for
example happens then the Queen will no
longer be able to come back into the
defense of the King so quickly as the e4
pawn would be in the way okay Queen
captures on b3 Nakamura grabs another
pawn and here a very interesting moment
in the game the engine gives rook
captures on a7 really cold-blooded move
simply grabbing upon restoring the
material balance on the board
but Carson doesn't gain anything from
drawing this game he has to win this
game and he really wants to win it he
retreats Bishop to e3 pressure is the c5
pawn we have looked to b7 now Nakamura
no longer allows cousin to capture on e7
and here if you capture Queen captures
Bishop captures on c5 you get a five and
still it would be very hard to push for
anything here with wood white or black
so Carlsen decides to keep the pressure
with pressure going rook to d6 now
threatening rook captures Bishop Bishop
to e7 is played attacking the rook and
now rook to d5 pressuring the c5 pawn
bishop to f8 now the rook is guarding
the e5 pawn as well so now Bishop
captures Bishop captures rook captures
and Queen to e6 offering a trade of
Queens across and declines Queen to e2
with a group to d7 and now rook captures
on b7 Queen captures on b7 and now comes
rope to d5 Queen to c7 and Queen to d2
so here we have a position material on
the board is completely equal Carson has
four points on the Kings side
Kanaka Mara has three but he does have a
passed pawn on the Queen side
so what Carson wants to do a crossing
would definitely enjoy grabbing the h7
point and then hopefully somehow
go into an end game with four points
against three but this is not possible
simply as you'll see in the game rook to
e8 by Nakamura he prefers to push the
past pawn we have rook to d7 Queen moves
and now f3 improving the position of the
pawns Queen c5 check King moves and now
Queen to c6 the King will be very safe
there because Black Sea 5 1 will not
allow for any tricks against the White
King and now white will try to put for a
for advantage but it will be very hard
rope to d6 we have Queen to c5 and now
rook to a6 Queen goes back we have Queen
to b3 pressuring the a7 pawn and now
King to h7 while the Queen and rook are
guarding the a7 point there is no way
there is no way whatsoever that white
can ever capture this pawn so what what
can be done here King to g3 by crossing
Queen to be 7 and the now comes Queen to
a3 we have f6 King to h2 and Queen to c7
so Nakamura can simply move the Queen
back and forth there is nothing Carson
can do here but he has to win this game
Queen to a1 we have Queen - b7 Nakamura
simply repeats we have Queen to a5 Queen
to d7 Queen to a2 and now Queen to e7
Queen to f2 we have Queen - b7 Queen
back to 82 and the Nakamura repeats
Queen to ace Queen to e7
if Crossin would repeat Nakamura would
also repeat and that this game would end
in a draw but Carson doesn't want a draw
Queen to d5 he attacks Nakamura stroke
on a 8 ok no big deal rook to b7 as the
pawn is only attacked once I only have
to defend it twice Queen to a5 attacking
the pawn twice and now rook to b7 simply
defending the point-wise
Queen e1 cousin finds a way to
complicate matters we have Queen to d7
and now comes Queen to h4 check King
moves ok no big deal and Carson retreats
Queen to f2 we have Queen to f7 and
here's the thing what Carson found he
finds Queen to a2 and you might think ok
exchanging Queens will only make it
easier to draw for block
and while this is true you have to put
yourself in Coulson's position here he
has to win this game he can never win it
while black is firmly controlling while
defending the a 7-point so even if
drawing with the queens of the board
would be even easier as he explored all
of his options of winning with the
Queen's on the board he will simply
remove the Queen's off the board so
Queen to have seven Queen to a - and now
captures captures and okay now it's a
rook against the a rook and the material
on the board is equal so how do you do
this
King gauge someone was played we have
rook to a6 now King to g6 h4 and here
King to h5 King to h3 we're up to f7 and
now g4 with check King to h6 and here
cousin plays King to g3 and now it seems
that the the most reasonable thing to do
is simply move the rug back and forth
and there doesn't seem to be away white
can push for any advantage here but
Nakamura decides for some reason to push
g5 and okay it's still most likely most
likely a draw but here comes and pushes
h5 and he does create a passed pawn here
so now a moment ago
Nakamura was the only player with a
passed pawn here now Carlson also has a
passed pawn but it's not the only the
only problem is not the passed pawn but
now also the passed pawn controls the g6
square so black will have a lot less
options when he has to make a move so
okay King to g7 and now King to F - now
Carlson's idea is he wants to bring the
King over well not with that route but
he wants to take the King over to the
Queen side and perhaps capture the a
7-point rook to be 7 king rook to a3 now
making room for the King King to h6 and
now King to e3 and here the best idea
for black would be to go rook to d7 not
allow the King to enter the game but
Carson would play a rope to d3 and then
regardless get his king over to the
Queen side while keeping the rocker -
defended the f3 pawn but this would
probably still be a blacks best bet here
but after King
three Nakamura decided to play a five he
gives up the a5 pawn for this counter
play and he thought that he will be able
to keep the king away cousin captures
the pawn we have worked the b3 check
King to have to look to be tortured and
King to g3 and okay Nakamura I did push
the King all the way back to g3 but you
know it's the game is not over King to
g7 rook to e7 check King moves back and
now comes Luke to a one King to g7 and
now rook to f1 preparing group to f2 and
now the king will be able to get back
into the game
rook to a 2 we have looked to f2
opposing the rook now you no longer have
the option of exchanging drugs because
you are now down upon and also why it
has a passed pawn rook to a3 rook to d2
making room for a king to enter rook to
a7 and now King to f2 King to f7 King to
e2 we have grouped to be seven and now
rook to d3 making room for the king I
rocked the B to check will not do really
anything King comes to e3 and then the
rook will move the King will be able to
enter the game this way so instead
Nakamura goes rock to a7 and now we have
King to d2 King e6 king c3 King to e7
King to see for rook c7 check King to b5
r up to see one across and simply blocks
any checks with the rock now the rock is
going in the f3 pawn and also protecting
the king came to f7 and now kink the b6
Rock the c2 rockin the b7 block doesn't
really have any any good replies here
Rock the c1 and King to b8 we have King
goes back and the now comes rook to b6
attacking the f6 pawn king g7 defending
and the now look the b7 check this was
very important King to g8 and now rook
to 67 opposing nakamura stroke and c1
rugby one check and now King can
approach the black King rugby three
attacking the pawn and now King to the 7
cut across and calculate precisely that
he has to of course give up the f3 pawn
to make progress here
rook captures in the now King to e6
we have rook to f4 attacking both bonds
the G and the e pawn and now comes h6 we
have King to h8 and the now comes rook
the b7 King goes back and now rook to g7
as black was enthused Wang King goes
back and the now comes King to f7 rook
captures an F on e4 and now comes King
to g6
rook to a4 and now rook to h7 was played
Nakamura was in check and here after you
know staring at the position in
disbelief for about some 10 minutes or
maybe less Nakamura decided to resign
the game why did he resign well after he
moves cousin has rook to e7 with the
threat of checkmate to prevent this you
have to go rook e8 I rotate and then
come simply King captures on f6 key for
15 captors and g5 and pretty much
whatever you do you will lose all the
material here and after all I said and
on white would be up to connected passed
pawns in a completely winning position
so after this rook to h7 check Nakamura
resigned and an unbelievable victory for
Magnus Carlsen in the final round of the
2008 18 Sinquefield Cup where he I mean
the position was very rich and you know
that whole Bishop captures on h6 was a
wonderful idea really an exciting moment
but then after Nakamura's rook e8 the
game pretty much went into a draw a face
but once again the world champion Magnus
Carlsen shows us that a drawn position
is not a drawn game if you wish you can
play it forever and the stronger player
not just you know the better player
regarding chess but the better nerves
the better psychology the better stamina
will in the end win you the game which
is something we were we witnessed in the
games of Bobby Fischer so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying the coverage of the 2018
single cup so far I would like to thank
Pierre Asaf muhannad Al Abdullah weren't
to Tyler and his body
mark Olson and Thomas Zimmerman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
I did receive other contributions as
well but I will have to thank you in the
other video as I only have room for five
people here but thank you as well I
will show the Iranian versus Greek video
soon and it's very interesting warrant
to twylar and his body are the two
gentlemen I've shown their photo on my
video the two gentlemen with Khurana one
of them was carrying Coronas big head
and he thanked me for showing that photo
in the video but unfortunately the the
gentleman at the same clothes chess club
did not so yeah I mean I'm very
unimpressed by how this whole thing with
the same to his chess club turned out as
like I always say I have the utmost
respect for all of their members you
know for years everyone especially he's
a legend I mean I myself would rather
watch yasser talk about anything for 10
hours rather than watch a 15 video I
made but I mean my 15 to 10 minutes 10
or 15 minutes videos are in no way a
threat to their life coverages or
anything they can only be an addition to
them you know as I always always invite
people to check out the original footage
to check out the live coverage I always
give credit to to everyone who's
involved sometimes I forget it but it's
not because I'm a mean or anything you
know I just forget forget to do it but
most likely in all of my videos it will
all be in the description below so
that's I mean that's very sad how you
know in my opinion how this turned out
but such is the way of chess obviously
and yeah i don't know i don't i don't
think Rex Sinquefield will be all that
impressed if he knew how his resources
were spent trying to prevent the
promotion of chess but yeah once again i
do hope you enjoyed that I think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
the Aragon vs Greece shoot game and the
wonderful sacrifice on f7 thank you all
and I'll see you soon